Scot done having my morning cup of
coffee and down here I can see the river
really started dropping last night
dropped a couple feet I'm gonna head
upriver make sure my fish will is not
high and dry I can't afford to just let
a functionable fish wheel go to waste
the waters been high for about two weeks
now I just kind of like planed out in
the last couple days and just dropped
overnight just like that and that's how
this river is it's constantly changing
Jessie Holmes relies on the resources
along the Nenana River to maintain a
subsistence lifestyle getting his fish
wheel up and running his crucial to
feeding himself and his team of sled
dogs for the year ahead
so fishwheel is made out of spruce log
grafts and it floats out in the river
what we do is we take it with big logs
and push it far out into the river into
a deep channel we drop the axle down and
the big baskets dip through the water
it's turning with the current because it
scoops down the fish have no place to go
so they swim right into the scoop scoops
them up now the purpose of a fish wheel
is to put up a large amount of fish I
can put up 900 fish in a day if the
fishings going good I need to be
catching fish and feeding the dogs fish
right now because it's the most
cost-effective way for me to be able to
keep these dogs this could be a real big
deal to me to not be able to use that
fish wheel my main goal is to not fall
in the river it's one of the fastest now
having wool waters in the US the Tanana
River is and there's just tons of silt
in here a minute you're in there the
silt starts filling your pockets filling
your clothes fill in your boots little
things can become big things quick
this thing's definitely up on the
sandbars the rivers drop a couple feet
here yeah it definitely looks like I got
my work ahead of me finding get this
thing out here on the water current soon
it's gonna get a lot worse because the
rivers drop them fast if I waiting any
longer on this it could put me out of
the season is stressful the stakes are
high and like it's very easy to mess up
with a fish wheel there's a lot of
things going on you got the current
thousands of pounds I mean this is gonna
be one hell of a job every minute the
ghost by is a minute wasted and another
couple inches of water loss possibly so
it's time to get to work bust this thing
out get on to the next process it's a
lot of work but it provides a lot of
food for the dogs there we go she's
moving